in the figure above lines L&K intersect
at Point Q if M is equal to 40 so this
right over here that right over there is
40 degrees am degrees so if M is equal
to 40 and p is equal to 25 so P so this
angle right over here is 25 degrees what
is the value of x encourage you to pause
the video and think about this on your
own so the big realization right over
here is to realize that this angle and
this entire angle are vertical angles
they're on the opposite sides of this
point of intersection at Point Q so
vertical angles are always going to be
they're going to always have the same
measure so this is 40 degrees then this
whole thing this whole thing is going to
be that whole thing is going to be 40
degrees and if that whole thing is 40
degrees then x plus 25 is going to need
to be equal to the whole 40 degrees so
let's write that down so x plus 25 X
plus 25 is going to be equal to 40
subtract 25 from both sides subtract 25
from both sides and we are left with X
is equal to 15 x is equal to 15 so X
this angle right over here is 15 degrees
or x is equal to 15 15 plus 25 is 40
it's a vertical angle it has the exact
same measure in degree or the exact same
measures this angle right over 40
degrees